this guy's a fascist as if you can't
make that what you think you're saying
we made this up you say that's a lie we
made really we could get the officers
here I'm not going to talk to this guy
I'm gonna talk with you you'd like both
of us to leave yes okay let's both go
welcome to the latest installment of
Crowder confronts now our first choice
in this channel is always civil
discourse when it's met with produce or
milkshakes to the face however sometimes
we have to pivot meat he's a member of
antiva who has a storied history of
violence he was arrested for assaulting
police officers at an ant 4 rally in
threw tomatoes at president Trump though
it should come as no surprise that he
missed by a mile
now during her recent change my mind at
Google headquarters in Austin Oh took to
Facebook posting our location publicly
and calling for others to milkshake me
quick recap you may recall professors
from the last installment he's the
teacher who labeled me a Nazi and
falsely spread a rumor about me
threatening his child because he's a
compulsive liar on the spectrum well
look who we found lurking in this serial
libel or social feed he wants someone to
light me on fire
we've escalated from chilled dairy
products to third-degree burns well
mister call me you're mr. heat miser
[Music]
start melting my clock I'm too much
[Music]
take it
[Music]
hey how are you man steven crowder
what's going on I got a question for you
I know that we disagree on things
politically I'm your heat miser by the
way but why would you want to light me
on fire
hey did yeah you did encouraging him to
light me on fire ah the old it wasn't me
excuse seems that we've heard this one
before why would you threaten to
firebomb my van or encourage other
people to do it
at first she just deny deny deny I think
it's okay to threaten a slash in ones
tires I didn't do it like what you meant
with killing members of ice for $500 a
pop we can discuss it at a neutral
meeting place I'm not discussing with
people who've made threats against my
son whose followers made threats against
my son I mean oh that's right every
single person we've confronted in the
history of ever good thing we have hard
evidence well do you want sit down and
talk about it she wants to know I'm
talking about it what would you sit down
grab a seat well not really a fascist I
don't encourage acts of violence I want
to be clear I'm not encouraging any acts
of violence here right now quite the
opposite do you really think that has a
role in today's political discourse
posting people's location asking if
they'd be lit on fire
you didn't post my location you didn't
do that and encourage people to milk
shake me milk shake light on fire why
don't you sit and talk about it and
maybe we could find some kind of a
common ground and I know I mean I know
you have a long history of felonies and
violent assault on police officers and
so you've been seen sort of as a folk
hero some people on the left but what do
you this is just genuine question why do
you think that's acceptable - did I
going to get an interview out of me man
I don't need to get an interview I just
want to know why you think that's
acceptable to do how do you not see
yourself as a fascist when you encourage
acts of violence do you not see that as
fascism
oh yeah well you know I just he
encouraged people to light me on fire
and post in my location so I'm just
trying to find out why you think that's
okay to do so we can talk about it with
the officers as if you can't make that
what you think you're saying we made
this up you say that's a lie we made
really yeah your and that's I know I
know you're here to me
I know I'm not a semi-attractive
antiphon we could get the officers here
I'm not going to talk to this guy I'm
gonna talk with you I'm just really
curious as to why you think it's okay
I'm not gonna spy labeling somebody
you'd like both of us to leave yes okay
let's both go curious question does it
make it okay to encourage people to
commit violent felonies because you
simply label them a fascist what about
me is fascist could you give me one
thing that I've said or encouraged that
would be fascist like just one thing
this is huge
well the only wasn't it was boring until
you lied and said that it wasn't you and
we're gonna be able to prove that now so
we're gonna know so everyone's gonna
know not only that you encourage
violence but you're a coward and not
even to stand behind your own conviction
goodbye you made that quote no we didn't
know we didn't we didn't we absolutely
didn't we'll prove it to millions of
people okay what day right here
12:41 p.m. and then post our location we
were there in Austin encouraging people
to milkshake us which you know there's
been a problem with concrete and
milkshakes and acid so would you disavow
any violence then you would actively
discourage people from committing acts
of violence because if you didn't write
that I would assume you have a problem
with it right would you say that right
now to the camera like hey listen man
they got this wrong I actively
discourage any violent I kind of hope
someone does such on fire do you really
know you said it do we faked that one
too yeah
yeah like you didn't say this this is us
edit again selectively yeah so you're
just a violent hateful person yeah there
you go is it is it does the word
recidivism mean anything to you
why do you justify violence against
people you disagree with it's genuinely
I don't understand and people like you
don't sit down the table on the show
you'd rather attack so I never get to
hear your opinion right I'm interested
that you are steven crowder right do you
mean like being out there and publicly
to change my mind when you decided to
encourage people to light me on fire and
milkshake me instead of showing up like
a man that kind of thing
Dow that kind of arrangement at this
point you can set the record straight do
you want to honestly declare your
convictions that you encourage violence
or do you want to actively discourage
violence well I guess just because
you're not behind a keyboard no tomatoes
we can buy you tomatoes I just you know
I don't understand why you think it's
okay to act this way and behaviors we're
both adults right I would never think of
encouraging someone to light someone on
fire posting their location ID well you
just did right now did you not say it
right now okay Michael Moore we're not
gonna edit this out of kindness I didn't
say that on like you made that tweet up
and then you said like why is it okay
it's not sweet its Facebook and you oh
so you originally said it because you
think I'm a fascist and now you're
saying you hope that someone likes me on
fire because we lied about you saying
that you would light me on fire
it doesn't matter do you know what
fascism means can you define it for me
go ahead wouldn't you would the use of
force would the use of force to silence
dissenting opinions be fascist is that
you did you do this was this you you
want to stand we made that I'm gonna
stand by that yeah I made that up that's
fake I was tempted to milkshake you in
there and I just figured like a
surrounded by all your friends no one
knowing listen there's no violence and
no one here would step in no matter what
you did no one here's looking at we've
never done it you deserve to get
milkshakes though why yeah why I had to
change my mind when you post the
location sitting down we talked with
people for hours do you think we deserve
to get milkshakes you're basically a
bench superior you don't debate with
people in good faith well thank you
that's very nice of you
why would you say hey I wanted to talk
with you right now but amount number but
it speak to you as violence it is
violence and it's not by to me it's by
the wall that's violence it's battery
it's a salt I'm not saying it's not
legal understand like if that to you is
violence like what's categorize those
pretty comfy life as a legal because
it's violent
I made your point that the left is
violent because we threw milkshakes and
you can encourage people to lie on fire
no no we didn't make it up you're a liar
too okay so here's a thing I know you
fancy yourself a keyboard warrior but
now you're gonna go down in history as a
liar not willing to own your convictions
and that's a problem for me
I'm multiple questions which I know you
haven't answered but why is it okay to
encourage violence okay for that to be
your only recourse like here you said
you wanted a milkshake what is your
first instinct to milkshake somebody why
is your first instinct to throw tomatoes
to assault the provide anything better
for the discourse oh like what who cares
if I milkshake you kind of wish I had no
you haven't because you live your life
as a coward so the same thing happened
right now it's just like you calling
people before we didn't have a
conversation because you said that well
it's not good because you've called for
violence against me in my team several
times man why do you think that's okay
do you not expect whatever be
consequences to your actions well I
guess there's you imposed your own
consequence so now I know what to expect
you know I mean it's hardly a
consequence I mean I know you've done
time in prison you'll probably do some
more after we file the report
you went to jail sorry County Jail drunk
tank for throwing tomatoes and
assaulting a police officer and it's
registered to the felony so you can see
what would be concerned if you
encouraged all the light me on fire man
okay no it doesn't matter we'll have an
overlay here you do that's what you do
you consistently encourage violence
that's all you do
what would be required for someone have
a differing opinion than yours and you
to not encourage violence so we know
it's not sitting down with a change my
mind open to all in Austin right
couldn't have been more civil completely
unedited the videos up that warranted
encouraging violence
how can someone disagree with you
express it publicly and not face the ire
of you're calling for violence what
would be an acceptable way for a
right-wing person or conservative to
express their opinion in Apes world view
like what would I need to do for you to
not encourage people to light me on fire
milkshake me I think a couple years down
the line you're probably gonna change as
a person and I think you'll look back on
this and understand why this was
important to people because there's been
a lot of folks out there who've had
violence committed against them just
because people like you label them a
fascist to justify horrendous actions so
you don't want to talk you don't want to
show up but I change my mind
table that's fascist to you sitting down
and discussing like two men that's
fascist to you
oh you've lied about it apparently
encouraging people to light someone on
fire and milk shake them and posting
their location publicly encouraging
violence simply to silence dissenting
opinion you don't see that as fascism do
you not see that violence to silence
opinion is fascism you are the fascist
do you get that you're the Mussolini
you're the Pol Pot what made you pick
this coffee shop and I heard it has good
coffee's a good coffee fine you want to
buy another coffee I'll buy you a coffee
man now there you have it remember kids
our first choice will always be civil
discourse here on this channel but if
you cross over the line into calling for
violence and physical harm to others I
will find you I will confront you and I
will shame
[Music]
hey did you enjoy this video of course
you did because you probably liked to do
this yourself to every Twitter egg who
refers to your mother as a [ __ ] but we
were able to do it so subscribe at the
notification bell there are other
Crowder confronts in the boxes here that
you can click but more importantly we
had to get on a plane with the whole
crew of people travel across the country
get our sound equipment get our kits
very expensive to do and we've been
demonetised so join up at louder with
greater comm slash mug club you get the
entire blaze catalog the full daily show
not available on YouTube and it ensures
that things like change my mind
undercover videos Crowder confronts
continue to exist because if you don't
join my club they're just gone and then
he was in LA where did it go well I told
you